[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a former teacher of the parkland school
shooter testifies for the defense i
strongly feel that nicholas is a danger
to the students faculty at the school i
do not feel that he understands the
difference between his violent video
games and reality plus the kobe bryant
crash scene photos will vanessa bryant
move forward with claims against los
angeles county at the state level and
the defense calls its first witness in
the federal sex crimes trial of r b
singer r kelly in chicago but first the
jury views crime scene locations in the
trial of pike county massacre defendant
george wagner iv law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
okay welcome everybody to the law and
crime daily i am your host imran ansari
in for brian buckmeyer
ahead of opening statements in the trial
of george wagner iv jurors visit crime
scenes of the pike county massacre
correspondent angenette levy joins us
from ohio with a location breakdown
for a second day in a row jurors in
george wagner the fourth murder trial
were taken to locations that are
important to the investigation into the
murders of eight members of the rhoden
and gilly families
the 12 jurors and six alternates rode a
school bus to union hill road for a jury
view they saw the three properties where
seven members of the rhoden and gilley
families were shot to death in the early
morning hours of april 22 2016. many of
the family members were sleeping when
they were shot in the head children in
the homes were left unharmed the
trailers have since been placed in
storage to preserve the crime scenes but
on chris rhoden senior's property you
can see a faded poster asking for clues
about who killed him and his family this
is a little bit like the hatfields and
the mccoys this is a little bit like one
family being very angry at another
family mark weaver is a former deputy
attorney general for the state of ohio
weaver says prosecutors allege the
wagner family is part of a criminal
enterprise and that they were part of a
conspiracy to kill the rodents and
hannah gilli so jake wagner and his
family could have full custody of the
daughter jake shared with hannah mae
rhoden the wagners are accused of
killing anyone who could have tried to
take custody of the little girl
jake and angela wagner have already
pleaded guilty and agreed to testify
against george and billy wagner jurors
also visited the home where the wagners
lived at the time of the murders it's
where prosecutors say shell casings were
found that had the same markings as
those found at the crime scenes they
also said they found charred pieces of
the rodent's surveillance camera system
stolen by the wagners that night to
cover their tracks you're talking about
a group of people a family group
that sat around kitchen table perhaps or
in the front room or on the front porch
and
allegedly
they planned
the slaughter of another family and
these visits to the four crime scenes
and other locations attached to the
wagner family are very important for the
jurors as they prepare to hear opening
statements next tuesday for law and
crime daily i'm angenette levy
okay joining us today is my co-host
terry austin and criminal defense
attorney matt mangino now i want to
start with you how common is it that
juries are allowed to view the scene of
a crime and what are the criteria for
the judge in allowing such a viewing
well the criteria first of all is that
that visiting the crime scene will
provide some uh meaningful opportunity
for jurors to to get a better context a
better understanding of what happened
particularly in this situation where
there's four separate uh crime scenes
you know what's interesting is we saw in
the cruz case the unprecedented
situation where you go into a crime
scene that is pristine that has been
kept exactly as it was on the day of
that terrible massacre and we saw
recently in the matthew moore case the
stage suicide where they went out to the
crime scene i believe before any
testimony was presented which is unusual
in itself but but here uh clearly this
was an appropriate uh opportunity for
the jurors to get a chance to see the
various crime scenes
and terry the jury is viewing four
different scenes together in fact they
even rode the bus together how difficult
is it not to discuss what they saw
well you know they are instructed not to
discuss the case before all of the
evidence is in
and when they go out to that crime scene
they are actually looking at what
exactly happened and where it happened
matt raised some really good points that
this evidence is being kept as it was
now this might not be pristine because
it's outdoors and all of that but i
think that most of the
viewings where it happened inside and
the gunshots took place is probably the
way it was when it happened at the time
i would think that those jurors would be
affected they'd want to talk about it
they're getting specific impressions and
they have emotions and they might say to
each other look can you see can you
isn't that amazing it happened right
here now i i suppose that talking about
it in that way wouldn't be any sort of
misconduct but i am certain that they
are trying very hard not to talk about
the case okay thank you matt and terry
and headed south to georgia where a 14
year old girl is arrested for setting
fire to an atlanta area walmart it
happened on august 24th at a walmart in
peachtree city georgia about 40 minutes
south of atlanta photos show the charred
aftermath of what was once the store's
grocery area it took about nine hours
for emerging emergency responders to put
out the flames that caused extensive
damage to the building three responding
officers were hospitalized with smoke
inhalation but they have since been
released officials say the 14 year old
girl responsible for the fire has since
been arrested and charged with first
degree arson her name has not been
released as she is a minor
and still ahead on law on crime daily
fresh off the heels of her win against
los angeles county vanessa bryant could
soon be headed back to court
but first our kelly's defense team calls
their first witness as the singer stands
trial for federal sex crimes
[Music]
welcome back a federal judge denies r
kelly's motion for acquittal as the
singer indicates he will not testify in
the trial
the 55 old convicted sex offender now
stands trial in illinois on federal sex
crimes charges
back in 2008 the singer was acquitted of
charges for creating a video of himself
having sex with a 14 year old at the
time the alleged victim and her family
denied their involvement but 16 years
later the accuser and her mother
testified for the prosecution saying
they lied about their involvement after
kelly threatened them the defense began
its case on thursday where kelly
indicated he would not be testifying the
first witness called was a former
chicago police officer kelly is being
tried alongside two co-defendants who
prosecutors say kept the singer's crimes
under wraps
okay terry co-defendant daryl mcdavid is
charged with child pornography and also
helping kelly rig the 2008 trial he said
he will testify what do you think we can
hear from this defendant
well first of all i think it's a mistake
to testify i mean he could
unintentionally open some doors in other
areas and of course he's going to be
subject to cross-examination and that's
going to be very difficult but look he's
the long-time business manager for kelly
he knows kelly he knows the operation
he's going to get up on that stand and i
think the jury is going to pay close
attention to what he has to say i think
he's going to be very defensive about
what he did about what kelly did and
what he's going to say is it was his job
to protect kelly and that he wasn't in
any way shape or form involved with
pornography and definitely not involved
with making a rigged 2008 case and with
trying to get witnesses not to testify
that was a big part of what was going on
in 2008 some of those witnesses got
phone calls and got phone calls from the
business manager and others allegedly
and were really frightened and did not
testify including the victim and her
mother so we'll see what happens but i
think he's going to be very defensive on
that stand and he's better be careful
when it comes up to cross-examination
okay and matt co-defendant milton brown
is charged with receiving child
pornography like kelly and he said he
wouldn't testify like kelly was that the
right move
well you know
you can't be compelled to
to testify as a defendant you have the
right to choose not to and the jury
can't really consider that uh
against you in terms of their
deliberations but
you know human nature
tells us that
jurors want to know
the defendant's version
of the case they want to hear from the
defendant they want to hear
why
they've been accused
why they're not
responsible for the actions that they've
been accused of so
well well they have no responsibility
you know
jurors want to know what they have to
say
all right thank you matt and terry and
switching now to idaho as attorneys for
lori valodebel half of the so-called
doomsday cult duo are seeking to ban
cameras from upcoming court hearings
claiming the media have abused their
privileges of filming and taking
photographs in court
prosecutors believe lori conspired with
her brother alex and husband chad dabell
to murder her children jj and tyler ryan
for social security money and as part of
a religious pact they're also charged in
the death of chad's former wife tammy
the children's remains were found in
june of 2020 months after they went
missing buried on chad's property in a
motion filed this week lori's defense
attorneys referenced a hearing two weeks
ago which was broadcast and recorded
with the judge's permission they claimed
the cameras set up in that hearing
zoomed in on balo and could have
violated attorney-client privileges
the attorneys are requesting that
cameras be banned or that only still
photography is allowed moving forward in
the case
valo and dave bell both face the death
penalty their trial is set to begin in
january of 2023
and coming up on the long crime daily
the defense continues its case in the
parkland school shooter penalty phase
trial
plus fresh off a win against los angeles
county vanessa bryant could pursue more
legal action why the release of the kobe
bryant crash photos could call for
invasion of privacy claims
[Music]
welcome back vanessa bryant's lawsuit
trial against los angeles county may
have come to a verdict last week but the
case isn't quite over brian along with
financial advisor chris chester sued los
angeles county after photos were taken
of the remains of their family members
including nba great kobe bryant their
daughter gianna and chester's wife and
daughter following a fatal helicopter
crash back in 2020 they filed the suit
claiming first responders took photos at
the crash site and shared them with
others through text messages and in
public
after several weeks of testimony a jury
awarded bryant 16 million dollars and
chester 15 million dollars by following
the verdict forms but that was later
adjusted to 15 million each after it was
discovered there was a clerical error
bryant still has another potential case
awaiting her in state court as she can
now move forward with the california
invasion of privacy claims which were
separated from the federal civil rights
claims before trial bryant has until
september 19th to decide whether she'll
pursue those claims related to the
actual taking of the photos whereas the
federal claims had to do with their
distribution
matt the state case has to do with the
actual taking of the photos while the
federal case had to do with their
distribution do you think this quick
case in state court will be easier to
defend than the one in federal court
well the issue is going to be invasion
of privacy uh
which is you know separate from the
civil rights action that was filed uh
you know we know based on testimony in
the federal case that that there were at
least eight um
firefighters or other uh emergency
personnel from
los angeles county that had taken
photographs and
what uh
bryant has to prove in in this state
case is that taking those photographs
was an invasion of privacy uh for her
family that that her loved ones who were
uh
killed in this accident uh their bodies
were on display and that that was an
invasion of her privacy and that she
was harmed by that that she was damaged
by that and she's entitled to
compensation for it
yeah terry this is an interesting
situation given the recent verdict do
you think that vanessa bryant will
pursue these state claims
you know what and mom i think she might
actually pursue these state claims they
were part of that federal case and they
were separated and they were brought for
a specific reason even though they were
separated i am certain that she still
probably wants restitution for the
invasion of her privacy there and so
she's going to make sure that all of
those defendants are held accountable
for all of those actions not just
distributing the photos but actually
taking unnecessary photos if they were
supposed to take photos of all of those
bodies well then that's one thing but i
think it could be deemed an invasion of
privacy if they weren't supposed to take
it some people might think that state
case is a waste of time it's a waste of
taxpayer dollars she's already had her
day in court
but i do think she is safe you know
setting the way for others and making
sure that those police officers and
first responders and firefighters follow
policy and don't do this again she has
every right i think to bring any claim
that she has in the state court as well
thank you terry and matt will be keeping
tabs on that case
and despite being denied 11 times the
man convicted of killing english
musician john lennon is up for parole
again
mark david chapman was sentenced to 20
years to life in prison after pleading
guilty to shooting john lennon four
times in front of his wife yoko ono as
he was walking into his luxury new york
apartment in december of 1980. chapman
was an out-of-work security guard from
hawaii who had a history of mental
illness he was first eligible for parole
22 years ago and he's been denied 11
times since
at the latest parole hearing and
subsequent denial in august of 2020
chapman told the parole board quote i
assassinated him because he was very
very famous and that's the only reason
i was seeking self-glory very selfish
he was set to appear for a parole
hearing in upstate new york sometime
this week
and when we come back life in prison or
the death penalty a florida jury must
now decide the fate of parkland school
shooter nick cruz
[Music]
welcome back a defense motion for
mistrial is denied on day 20 of the
parkland school shooter penalty phase
trial
in february 2018 a then 19 year old
gunman opened fire at marjory stoneman
douglas high school killing 17 people
and injuring 17 others last year the
gunman pleaded guilty to all counts a
florida jury will now decide whether he
receives life in prison or the death
penalty
on thursday defense attorneys motioned
for a mistrial arguing their clients
constitutional rights were violated when
an earlier evidentiary motion on the
introduction of a swastika was not
decided
judge elizabeth sher denied the motion
the defense then called carry on to the
stand who worked as the defendant's
middle school teacher jan read excerpts
from her notes to the jury
i strongly feel that nicholas is a
danger to the students and faculty at
the school i do not feel that he
understands the difference between his
violent video games and reality he's
constantly showing aggressive behavior
and poor judgment his drawings in clash
show violent acts people shooting at
each other creepy sexual pictures dogs
with large penises
he has pretended to masturbate in class
he uses bell language and disregards
everyone around him nicholas has been
reprimanded on many occasions verbally
referrals is etc and continues to act in
the same manner over and over again
showed linda nick's work and explained
the seriousness of it she did not seem
very concerned she claimed that he's a
boy going through puberty we also
discussed his obsession with guns and
violence
he stated that he's interested in buying
a bb gun from walmart and was asking his
mom repeatedly
if he could get the gun promising that
he would just shoot at trees
okay let's bring in matt and terry matt
i'll start with you
the judge got pretty upset today mostly
with defense counsel how do you think
she is managing her courtroom thus far
well i mean this is it has been a a long
trial and it's going to continue to
go on i mean i think she has
managed the courtroom
as well as you would expect a judge to
do i mean she's gained some um leeway
when it was appropriate uh but there's a
lot of issues here and and the one issue
uh you know that came up today with
regard to
uh you know a
what may be some undue influence by the
prosecution on one of the witnesses uh
is certainly an issue that i don't think
is going to go away i think the uh
record has to be established on exactly
what that conversation was about uh so
there's there are a lot of issues you
know separate from actually the
testimony that's that's been coming out
here uh from the defense and i think
what the defense is trying to do is say
hey the system failed nicholas cruz uh
the school district failed nicholas cruz
and try to create some sympathy among
these jurors for that
premise
and terry the defendant's former teacher
mentioned a lot of disturbing behavior
in his middle school years saying the
school wasn't equipped for his needs
should these actions have been a warning
sign of things to come
almost definitely they should have been
a warning sign the actions that he did
while he was in middle school were
really far worse than anyone else had
ever done and they testified as much
that she basically said she hadn't seen
anything quite like this before i mean
not only did he have scribble and notes
and drawings that were inappropriate and
offensive but his behavior was
violent as far as she was concerned and
she tried to downplay it a little bit
but it basically was acting out against
her acting out against other students
she in fact was afraid she had the
assistant principal come in and sit with
her because she was afraid and
even though they don't want to call it
bullying it was bullying because if you
verbally try to make someone fear you
that could be deemed bullying and so i
definitely think they saw this behavior
and it was behavior that should have
been a clue that something else might
come ahead
thank you matt and terry and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you